the essence of sport is uncertainty that
you don't know
who is going to win but the jeopardy
that makes football appealing to fans is
the last thing
owners want which is why 12 european
clubs
have committed to join a new super
league backed by a three and a half
billion euro loan from u.s investment
bank jp morgan
15 founder members will be granted
between 100 and 350 million euros each
just for joining the competition they'll
share projected revenues of 5
billion euros a year through media
rights and sponsorship aggressively
marketed
in still growing markets in asia and
africa the champions league they plan to
replace currently generates
3.2 billion euros a year now to try and
win
support the super league clubs say
they'll give eight percent of revenue
worth
at least 400 million euros a year to
other european clubs in solidarity
payments
that's more than uefa currently
distributes now this closed model will
be familiar to the american owners of
manchester united
liverpool and arsenal all of whom have
stakes in u.s sporting clubs that
operate in highly
profitable closed franchise systems
manchester united shares let by 10
in early trading following the
announcement and the money
matters tottenham have gross debts of
more than 800 million
pounds largely incurred building a new
stadium while barcelona's debts are more
than 400 million pounds
and real madrid's almost 300 million
and all the clubs face financial
challenges accelerated
by the pandemic a number of these clubs
not all of them
have handled their affairs very badly
they are
hugely in debt i think one of the
english clubs who
you can work out who may be i believe
has more or less a billion pounds
of debt so i think the spanish clubs i
know we all know that spanish clubs
uh have massive debt so i think that
this is a way of dealing with a
desperate situation
uh which kobe has accentuated
now this may yet prove part of a
negotiation to get more income
from existing competitions but if not
these clubs are calculating that
broadcasters and ultimately supporters
will pay more for the certainty of
guaranteed
games between the biggest teams than
they will for the occasional
upset and they may be right there are
many ways to lose money in modern
football
but betting against cynicism is not
usually one of them